[Music]
have you ever thought about what you'd
do with your life if you do retire one
day
i i was just thinking about it yesterday
i never had an answer for that that
question until just a couple nights ago
and
while i'm far too old i would do it i
would want to i would want to pitch for
the yankees
bruce willis is stepping away from
acting following a diagnosis of aphasia
on wednesday bruce's family took to
social media to announce the news with
ex-wife demi moore daughter rumor willis
and her other siblings writing this
alongside a photo of the sixth sense
star to bruce's amazing supporters as a
family we wanted to share that our
beloved bruce has been experiencing some
health issues and has recently been
diagnosed with aphasia which is
impacting his cognitive abilities as a
result of this and with much
consideration bruce is stepping away
from the career that has meant so much
to him the hardest job in the world is
to make someone laugh
according to johns hopkins medical
center aphasia is a language disorder
caused by damage in a specific area of
the brain that controls language
expression and comprehension and leaves
a person unable to communicate
effectively with others aphasia is
frequently the result of a stroke in the
joint instagram post they shared that
although it's been quote a really
challenging time for our family they're
so appreciative of the continued love
and support they've received from fans
adding we are moving through this as a
strong family unit and wanted to bring
his fans in because we know how much he
means to you as you do to him as bruce
always says live it up and together we
plan to do just that the 67 year old
action movie legend immediately began
trending on social media with fans
sharing their disbelief and sadness over
his health diagnosis